[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département aujourd'hui mercredi 28
juin parole à sandrine grand gang
secrétaire départemental du parti
socialiste et soutien de benoît hamon
nous parlerons avec elle du mouvement
lancé 110 par l'ancien candidat
socialiste à la présidentielle et de
l'avenir du ps parole aussi dans cette
émission à thomas levet ancien vainqueur
de l'open de golf de france alors que la
compétition
elle débute demain à saint quentin en
yvelines une nouvelle édition une
nouvelle dimension grâce à l'arrivée
d'un sponsor chinois sandrine grand
gombe
bonsoir sa secrétaire départemental du
ps je le disais soutient depuis des
années de benoît hamon au sein du ps
aussi vous avez forcément vécu au plus
près les deux défaites du ps et de votre
candidat ces dernières semaines
aujourd'hui la page est tournée dix
jours seulement j'ai envie de dire après
les élections législatives ça y est vous
êtes passé à autre chose
oui parce qu'en fait c'est la fin d'un
long processus dire que nous on l'a
vécue en interne depuis 2014 que la
première la première alerte avait été
les municipales de 2014 où on avait bien
analysé qui avait quelque chose qui
n'allait pas et qui avait un décalage
entre ce que faisait le gouvernement
qu'on avait porté au pouvoir et le
ressenti sur sur localement ou les gens
n'étaient pas contents donc finalement
c'est presque un soulagement aujourd'hui
de se dire bon voilà on est arrivé au
bout d'un cycle et appartiennent dans
mon porte des idées
les indians ont pas changé sont toujours
là donc on veut aller porter mais
peut-être différemment autrement oui
justement pour pour passer à autre chose
et et préparer l'avenir benoît hamon
organise samedi le mouvement du 1er
juillet c'est le nom officiel
un mouvement pour faire quoi
concrètement est ce que c'est une
première étape pour construire un
nouveau parti politique pour instaurer
des nouvelles idées au sein du ps parti
politique je ne sais pas on verra mais
il ya une demande forte de gens qui sont
qui ont fait la campagne qui étaient
parfois encarté au ps parfois chez les
verts parfois au pc par fouet et plein
de gens
la société civile qui ont adhéré à la
campagne qui attendent un débouché
politique aujourd'hui parce que des
idées qui ont été portées des thèmes
nouveaux qui ont permis d'ailleurs de
faire débat que ce soit le revenu
universel que ce soit la taxe sur les
robots que ce soit la question bernard
août tous ces sujets qui sont des sujets
devant nous les perturbateurs
endocriniens avec la question des
pesticides ça fait l'actualité donc ça
c'est des sujets qui sont là devant nous
et sur lesquels les gens ont envie de
réfléchir envie qu'on ce qu'on se
connaît des propositions fortes et donc
le mouvement là qui se lance c'est ça
c'est nouveau offrir un cadre pour
ensemble réfléchir et après on verra
sur quoi ça veut dire revoir le
peut-être le programme de benoît hamon
de la présidentielle pour pour faire
émerger de nouvelles idées mais
différemment
hier le revenu universel que ce lien il
ya un socle de propositions et après
c'est qu'on va remettre en débat
et puis tous ceux qui ont envie
justement qui se sentent de gauche parce
que là on est dans une période de grande
confusion ou les cartes ont été abattus
dans cette explosion du système
politique
en même temps il ya des fondamentaux qui
restent et moi je crois et c'est
l'analyse que fait benoît hamon que on a
quand même des fondamentaux sur ce
qu'est né de levie de droite ce qu'est
une idéologie de gauche et se comporte
en termes de valeur sûre pour l'égalité
la justice et ça il faut continuer
d'alimenter la réflexion
justement vous allez parler de quoi
quels sont ces valeurs que vous allez
mettre en avant ce samedi c'est c'est
l'écologie le travail la démocratie
c'est les rois principes et les trois
piliers
après si on veut changer la manière de
faire je vais pas vous dire voilà ça va
être ça ça ça parce que l'idée c'est
justement de liverpool entre thématique
de faire venir le maximum de gens qui je
sais qu'il ya des écrivains il ya des
artistes
il ya d'aider des gens du monde
associatif qui vont venir il y aura des
poids lourds politiques aussi c'est
important pour il y aurait ensuite le
sera aussi en suisse et au bureau
martine aubry on pense à eux je sais que
christiane taubira ne peut pas être là
mais elle est en soutien de benoît ils
sont ils sont très proches
il y aura je sais bien laurent indiquent
ils
le mouvement l'intéressait je crois
qu'il devrait être là cécile duflot sera
là yannick jadot sera sera la lucarne
gounass à des gens qui viennent
d'horizons très différents et qui
veulent en fait travailler à ça un peu
faire émerger des nouvelles idées pour
la suite et les gens me dire derniers
résistants derniers députés ps sont
également invités à venir vous avez un
confirmation c'est là dessus car moi je
ne gère pas le fichier de ceux qui
viennent qui se met ce qui est sûr c'est
que le chiffre un et qu'on a aujourd'hui
et un chiffre réel c'est pas des
chiffres conclut on n'avait que les
partis politiques ont l'habitude parfois
d'annoncer des choses de manière un peu
outrancière et ce qui fait que tout est
décrédibilisé mais l'a formellement on a
vraiment 15000 personnes qui se sont
connectés pour dire sur le site on
viendra pas je sais pas combien seront
là et ça veut dire qu'il ya un vrai
mouvement
il ya une vraie demande de gens qui
n'ont jamais été aussi dans les partis
politiques qui disent nous on en vit
dans le l'espèce de chaos actuelle de
participer à la reconstruction de la
gauche à vous disiez en ce moment on est
un peu dans la confusion la plus totale
entre la france insoumise ce mouvement
là le parti socialiste qui semble se
chercher où se situe ce mouvement entre
les pros macro et les profonds france a
soumise cet espace est un espace ouvert
pour l'instant qui est conçu comme un
espace ouvert qui est trans partisan
donc on verra si ça devient ensuite un
mouvement politique à proprement parler
structuré comme un parti politique moi
je crois comme notre démocratie elle a
besoin des partis politiques
je pense que les partis politiques
peuvent évoluer peuvent naître mourir
mais c'est un élément important de la
démocratie d'avoir des structures
politiques donc peut-être que ça
deviendra un particulier pour l'instant
c'est pas ça pour l'instant c'est un
mouvement qui est trans partisan qui est
un lieu un lieu qui permettent de venir
échanger et comment ce mouvement se
situe-t-il par rapport aux gouvernements
d'edouard philippe et de d'emmanuel
macron c'est de l'opposition à ce que
vous voyez émerger pour le clairement
manquer dans l'opposition à tout ce qui
est annoncé sur les lois de travail
non il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté sur le
positionnement politique
après benoît hamon un titre personnel
avait dit que sur la loi de moralisation
et la vôtre s il y avait un certain
nombre d'éléments donc il s'agit pas de
dire on va voter contre toutes les lois
s'est passé une grande partie ont dit
mais voilà tout ce qui est lié à aux
propositions économiques et sociales ne
vont pas dans le sens de ce qu'on défend
après voilà c'est une offre politique
nous ont dit que ça nous convient pas
pour revenir à de l'actualité un peu
plus locale dans les yvelines
onze députés de la république en marche
un des républicains plus d'élus au
conseil départemental l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines on le sait qui
a basculé à droite en 2014 la gauche
at-elle encore un avenir j'ai envie de
vous demander dans les yvelines
et si oui quel avenir oui parce que il
ya les élections mais les mouvements
politiques c'est pas simplement avoir
des postes
heureusement c'est aussi porter des
idées c'est irrigué aussi le le débat
politique c'est aussi nous là l'objectif
c'est aussi de peut-être regagné un peu
la bataille culturelle qu'on a laissé un
peu de côté c'est à dire travailler
aussi sur le fond je peux aussi vous
allez pouvoir peut-être pas lancer un
mouvement mais faire défaire des
proposer des mets là concrètement raison
peut y aura des hommes il y aura des
comités locaux allaient qui seront la
déclinaison de ce qui va se passer au
niveau national donc on aura des comités
locaux en fonction de ce qu'ils ont
envie aussi de s'investir et puis après
la vie politique elle va très vite aussi
donc c'est un peu l'idée c est ce qu on
est capable d'offrir une offre d'avoir
une offre politique qui soit crédible
cohérente et avec une parole qui
tiennent à ce qu'à un moment donné ce
qu'on nous reproche aussi des gens et ce
qu'on voit
j'étais effondrée de voir comment le
président de l'assemblée nationale a été
élu alors qu'on nous avait dit que ce
serait une femme ça en donné il faut
arrêter de raconter n'importe quoi et
essayer d'avoir un discours qui
correspondent aux actes politiques que
l'on que l'on pose après les dernières
questions personnelles jean christophe
cambadélis a démissionné du parti
socialiste après la défaite des
élections législatives vous vous restez
secrétaire départemental du ps n'a pour
l'instant on attend un congrès c'est lé
congrès 1 qui après je sais pas du tout
dans les mois qui viennent comment ça se
boit niveau
pour l'instant oui mais je pas vocation
à rester première fédérale éternellement
merci sandrine grands groupes d'être
venu en plateau vous êtes pour le moment
de secrétaire départemental du ps dans
les yvelines
merci à vous notamment aux poursuit
cette émission avec du sport et la 101e
édition de l'open de france de golf qui
débute ce jeudi à saint quentin en
yvelines
le rendez vous pas cette année dans une
nouvelle dimension en intégrant les
rolex séries sans cercle de tournois de
haut niveau qui a permis d'attirer des
têtes d'affiché françaises et
internationales pour nous parler de
l'événement notre journaliste michael et
demi d'euros a rencontré cette semaine à
paris le versailles et thomas levet
vainqueur de l'open de france en 2011
regardez
alors je suis avec eux thomas levet
l'open de france va débuter là dans
quelques jours
quelles sont vos impressions par rapport
à cet open de france mais déjà c'est un
open de france qui a grandi vraiment
grandi la dotation à a doublé par
rapport à l'année dernière à une
droguerie au professionnalisme de
l'équipe d'organisation il ya quelques
changements
on voit qu'ils sont nous
nouveau dans l'organisation du tournoi
parce qu'ils découvrent le site et donc
on découvre le
les points positifs les points négatifs
et les endroits où ça va ça va vraiment
peut poser problème
et puis d'autres endroits où vraiment la
route du bail
il ya vraiment rien à faire et ventre
ils ont ils ont un beau challenge à
relever parce que l'open de france c'est
un endroit qui est très très vieux c'est
un 3e tournoi qui a le plus ancien du
circuit européen
vous avez gagné tournois en 2011 quelle
est la formule tout simplement pour
remporter ce tournoi
resté très calme c'est un parcours qui
est très exigeant qui est très compliqué
mantha mentalement
visuel c'est vraiment compliqué à gérer
et donc c'est un parcours qui demande
beaucoup beaucoup de calme beaucoup
d'expérience et pas mal de connaissances
parce que c'est un parcours où il faut
jouer avec son plan de jeu et pas avec
le plan de jeu des autres c'est pas
parce que l'autre tape un drive à 300
mètres sur un trou qu'il faut essayer de
le copier faire la même chose c'est de
temps en temps poussé la balle
intelligemment sur ce parcours là c'est
plutôt pas mal vous rassurer les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent en ce
moment est ce qu'il y aura du spectacle
quand même excuse où ils achètent ce
qu'ils ont dû spectacle devient un
problème aura du spectacle il ya de très
grands noms et les joueurs français sont
un petit peu revanchard par rapport aux
niveaux leur niveau de jeu et leur début
de saison je pense que y en a beaucoup
qui ont omis de se faire pardonner
pendant cet open et je serais pas
surpris d'avoir une belle surprise
française où sont le bien fonds si
loulou aussi mauvais sur cet open de
pouce sur ce parcours là ce sera plutôt
le style de raphaël jacquelin qui a
l'expérience pour lui et j'attends un
coup d'éclat de la presle de rappel
parce que depuis le début de l'année il
n'a pas assez bien joué par rapport à sa
classe naturelle donc je pense qu'un
gars comme lui peut faire très fort
victor dubuisson vous y croyez ou pas
cette année
oui à voir victor il peut gagner
n'importe quel tournoi du monde
le jour où il a le jeu en place il peut
gagner à n'importe quel moment donc
victoire est bien sûr dans les vins les
favoris et c'est à lui maintenant il ya
2 rue oui il pleut il pleut il peut très
bien jouer ici c'est un parcours qu'il
connaît très bien et est donc de faire
une lui aussi une belle surprise
on peut parler aussi l'alexander lévis
alex pour ce genre de parcours là c'est
un joueur qui attaque beaucoup et on
sait que le groupe national c'est pas un
parcours qu'on attaque beaucoup donc
rolex havas et essayer de ceux de gags
de garder sa fougue un petit peu sous
contrôle et essayer de faire de faire
une performance comme ça en étant un bon
d'être beaucoup plus calme ça va être
plus dur je pense bien qu'il soit plus
en forme que les autres merci beaucoup
thomas levet et vous allez j'en doute
pas aller à l'open de france ce week end
oui bien sûr bien sûr j'y suis sereine
je vais commenter pour la télévision et
ensuite je présenterai les joueurs au
départ du 1 les deux derniers jours ok
merci beaucoup merci merci c'est la fin
de ce set 8 les invités pour ce soir
prochain rendez vous demain 10 il a
retrouvé toutes nos séquences sur notre
site internet tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application de tv fil 78 excellente
soirée à tous
[Musique]